um
[Applause]
what's this one
is that minute some minutes okay morning
everybody
welcome to the licensing board on this
lovely gray day
um a bit of housekeeping fire alarm
procedures if the fire alarm is
activated please take the stairs down to
the reception area and out the building
to the green Hawley Square which is the
assembly point please do not use the
lifts officers will assist you in advice
when it's deemed safe to return to the
council offices General announcements um
filming a device that if filming takes
place anyone in attendance in the public
areas may have their image captured we
don't have anyone public at OS Dewey
today
um
does anyone intend to be a meeting
no okay live streaming I'd like members
to know
um that this committee meeting will be
streamed live and uploaded in its
entirety onto thanic District councils
YouTube channel
so I hope you've all done your hair
today
um mobile phones with everyone present
please ensure that their mobile phones
are turned silent and that they are not
used to make or receive phone calls in
the in this room whilst the meeting is
in progress
are there any apologies for absence
all right
apologies from councilor Huxley okay
councilor Curry Council
thank you
um Declarations of Interest are there
any Declarations of Interest
no okay agenda item three minutes of the
last meeting police can have a member
proposed and second at the minutes of
the licensing board meeting held on the
26th of July 2022 be approved as a quick
record could I please have a proposer
counselor
um Saunders and councilor scoby second
do members agree
um licensing subcommittee minutes please
can I have a member propose and second
that the minutes of the licensing
subcommittee meeting held on 3rd of
August 2022 be approved as a correct
record could I have a proposer and
secondary please councilor scoby
proposes and councilor um
shrub you know always think of your
second name of something else though
um team members agree
thank you
um agenda item five driver training as
an enforcement option for licensing
board please can I ask Alison Stocker
senior technical support team manager to
introduce the report
foreign
good morning all
um yeah as you're aware we have no
drivers to go to board today
um however licensing would like to
introduce a new enforcement option for
your consideration for drivers that are
coming to board this would include
remedial driving physical driving test
and or a disability awareness course
so basically if we have drivers that we
have complaints about with regards to
seriously bad driving then we would be
interested in putting them through a
driving course suspend their license and
then issue them with the driving course
this would be payable by themselves
once this has been achieved and passed
we would then unsuspend them and they
would have their license back thank you
do members have any questions or
comments to make
councilor scoby
I think this sounds very very sensible
and hopefully will mean that some of the
work that comes this way that's fairly
uh
Miner won't do so I support it
councilor Wing a great great move I
think just to make people aware and the
disability thing is particularly uh good
as well because we do have a significant
number of vulnerable people that
actually use our taxis could we also
build in to that that obviously that's a
theory side equality and inclusion and
also safeguarding because I've been
quite shocked at the lack of
safeguarding knowledge that that a lot
of our taxi companies and our and the
taxi drivers that come here don't seem
to have an under understanding of of the
issues around safeguarding and that also
I mean safeguarding covers the driver
themselves as well because if it you're
obviously safeguarding everybody
including including including the people
that are actually running run driving
the taxis so I welcome it all fully
support it thank you
yeah thank you just to make you aware
that the drivers at present do do a
safeguarding course
um however we are looking to include
disability and other courses in that as
you're aware we're looking to hopefully
bring in a policy sometime next year and
these will all be covered within that
I've got a question
um so obviously look at the training
courses like green lamp and Blue Lamp
and the different areas and what they
use including Swale and so and I just
wanted to
um ask how you're going to determine
because I realize that some of them are
more expensive than others and you know
obviously the cost goes to the driver I
mean how are you going to determine
which training provider you're using
I think looking at the report it would
actually be down to you for the severity
of the course which one would be
preferable for them to use so they are
slightly different I think only green
Penny actually do a physical driving
course which is what we're aiming for
and at the same time they would check
the vehicle over and make sure that it
was roadworthy as well so it's it would
depend I think on the severity of which
case you're dealing with
are there any other questions or
comments from the committee
the board has been asked to agree to the
requested changes to the current
guidelines could I have a proposer
um councilor Potter
pots
I need to upgrade my contact lenses
that's the wing second
that's great thank you very much um do
members agree they all agreed that's
great thank you
um agenda item six
vehicle plates for scrap metal
collectors please can I ask Alison
Stocker senior technical support team
manager to introduce the report
hello
um so this came about
um whereby we operate an opposite so
once a month we attend with the rural
police local police multi-agencies
whereby we focus on scrap metal dealers
licensed and unlicensed it came about
that we were stopping a lot of licensed
Vehicles which was fine obviously we're
doing the checks however Dover have
introduced a plate scheme and talking to
the trade they would really well
complaints to be put on the rear of
their vehicles to show that they are
fully licensed fully insured and also
helping public out as well with regards
to fly tipping Etc so my proposal is
that we have plates put on the rear of
all our license scrap metal vehicles
thank you
um
oh do you have questions Harry yeah
what's some of the cost of these plates
so they are going to be the same plates
as our private horror and Hackney
Carriage
um so all the software is already on the
system
um and we will at the moment be using
the private hire and Hackney Carriage
brackets and their
um and their plastic
covers if you like the upgrades to the
system will be done free of charge by
MoGo
oh sorry
um yeah the the MoGo who deal with the
plates are upgrading our system free of
charge so the first year we will be
issuing the plates to the drivers for
free
but it is a minimum fee I think of I
think I'll put it in the report actually
let me have a look
yeah things about something about 14
pounds but we will it's it's minimal but
we will be charging in rate with the six
percent if they lose those plates they
will then have to pay for those it's
just to get the ball rolling where we
would issue the plates for free to start
off with
do any other members of the board or
committee have questions for
a lesson no okay
um so the board has been asked to agree
to the requested changes to the current
guidelines
um could I have a proposer and a second
counselor Wing councilor scoby
um do members agree I agree
thank you
so thank you that concludes the business
for today's meeting
well I can talk to you about a court
case yesterday if you're interested okay
so the meeting closed at 10 09. yeah I
like it thank you we uh we went to court
yesterday we've got an unlicensed
vehicle